네. 안녕하세요. 빌사남입니다. 제가
오늘은 위치가 더 안 좋지만 건물을
멋지게 신축을 해서 더 비싸게 매각된
사례를 좀 소개를 해 드리려고
합니다. 그래서 지금 뒤에 보이는이
주택 낡은 주택 건물이랑 안쪽에
보시면 멋지게 신축한 그 건물이
보이는데 일단 저 신축한 건물은 올해
5월에 팔렸습니다. 매각이 됐는데
돼지가 한 120평 정도 돼요. 근데
170억 정도에 매각을 했습니다.
건물을 지은 상태에서 공실 상태긴
했거든요. 그래도 한 몇 개월 정도
공실 상태로 있다가 매각이 된
사례입니다. 그래서 지금 저 건물
같은 경우에는 도로 조건이 그렇게
좋지 않아요. 지금 여기 보시면 약간
언덕길에 위치하고 있습니다. 그래서
지금 주차장 있는 부분이 아마 이제
지하 1층으로 인정받아서 이렇게
오픈돼 있는 걸로 예상이 되는데 건물
안에 들어가서 보시면 진짜 너무 잘
지었어요. 설계에 신경을 진짜 많이
쓰고 그리고 자재라든지 이런 것도
신경을 되게 많이 썼습니다. 그리고
여기가 일종이에요. 네. 일종인데도
불구하고 저렇게 건물을 멋지게 잘
뽑아냈습니다. 그래서 진짜 여러분들이
뭐 신축 계획하시는 분들 계시면 진짜
저 건물 한번 보셨으면 좋겠어요. 그
정도로 제가 봤을 때는 저 정도
면적에 그리고 저 용도 지역에 정말
잘 지은 그런 건물로 저는 생각을
하고 있습니다. 근데 저 건물이 저
정도에 팔렸는데 지금 보이시는이 주택
있잖아요.이 주택도 올해 5월 달에
동일하게 매각이 됐습니다. 그래서
이거 같은 경우에는 돼지가 더 커요.
지금 안쪽에 있는 건 120평이고
이거는 돼지가 무려 150평 가까이
됩니다. 그래서 돼지는 더 큰데 이게
더 싸게 팔렸어요. 이게 146억에
팔렸습니다. 물론 이제 저기 같은
경우에는 신축비가 들어가긴 했지만
위치가 여기가 더 좋거든요. 여기가
도로가 좀 더 높고 그리고 코너변에
위치하고 있고 그리고 이거는 한번
설계를 떠 봐야 될 거 같긴 하지만
저 역건물 같은 경우에는 지금 저쪽이
지하 2층입니다. 두 개층을 인정을
받아요. 그래서 지금 보이는 저
주차장 부분이 지하 2층입니다.
그래서 제가 봤을 때 이것도 만약에
설계 떠 가지고 올리면 여기가 지하
2층으로 인정받을 가능성도 꽤
크거든요. 그래서 지하 2층 뭐 1층
1층 하면은 지금 저기 옆에 보이는
저 건물 정도의 어 높이로 되지
않을까 싶습니다. 그래서 이거이 지금
땅 같은 경우에는 건물 지으면 굉장히
좀 멋있게 나올 만한 어 그런
부지라고 보시면 될 거 같아요.
제가이 사례를 통해서 말씀드리고
싶은게 뭐냐면 물론 이제 건물을
매입할 때 입지나 이런게 굉장히
중요하긴 하지만 지금 뒤에 저 매각된
사례처럼 공간을 잘 활용하고 멋지게
만드느냐에 따라서 가치가 또
달라지기도 합니다. 그러니까 지금
보면은 여기가 지하 2층이에요.
그 이게 지금 전면이 엄청 넓어요.
그리고 여기가 그 브라이트 아시죠?
브라이트는 바로 앞인데 가시성도 훨씬
좀 좋고 여기가 이제 지하
2층입니다.
요렇게 돼 있네. 6층까지 이렇게 돼
있네. 여기가 아마 이제 지하 2층일
거예요. 지금 요렇게는 이제 1층으로
돼 있지만. 네. 지하 2층, 지하
3층, 그다음에 지하 1층 1 2 3
4 이렇게 돼 있을 겁니다. 여기도
일종이에요. 똑같이. 네. 네.
그래서 저는이 땅도 되게 좋은 거
같아요. 지금 지하 지금 여건물도
그렇지만 만약에 지하 2층으로
인정받는다라고 하면은 공간 활용도도
되게 좋고 1종 같이 않은 거의
2종급의 땅이라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 요쪽 부분 같은 경우에는
지금 역건물처럼 다 주차장으로 빼면
될 거 같거든요. 4억으로 임대해
주기에는 되게 좋은 땅인 거
같습니다. 근데 지금 저기 제가
공실이라고 했잖아요. 지금 인테리어
공사를 하고 있는데 아마 매입하신
분이 직접 쓰시지 않을까 싶습니다.
그리고 매입하신 분이 재벌 분이세요.
아마 기사에 많이 나갔는데. 네.
여기가 학동공원이거든요. 저 예전에
총각 때 여기 근처에 살았거든요.
여기가 되게 조용하고 뭔가
거주하기에도 좋고 이렇게 사무실
쓰기에도 되게 좋은 것 같습니다.
지금 저 건물이에요. 진짜 너무 잘
뽑았고 저 상부층의 뷰가 되게
좋아요. 주차장도 너무 잘 뽑았어.
예전에 이오리 씨 주택이었다가 이제
신축한 건물인데 이것도 되게 비싸게
팔렸죠. 전 진짜 이거 사례는 좀
많이 참고하시면 좋을 거 같아요.
아, 이거
대박인데.
와, 충고도 진짜 넓고 여기 앞에
지금 테라스도 그렇고
와 그래서 건물 도로 조건이라든지
위치가 좀 더 떨어지긴 하지만 저렇게
멋지게 신축을 해서 비싸게 매각할 수
있다라는 그런 사례를 좀 보여 준게
아닌가 그렇게 생각을 합니다.
그러니까 여러분들이 막 물건을 살
때도 이게 포장지를 어떻게 하냐에
따라 다르거든요. 뭐 제가 예를
들어서 뭐 어디 가서 물품을 살 때도
진짜 포장지에 따라서 살지 말지가
결정되고 가치가 달라지는 것처럼
건물도 어떻게 만드느냐에 따라서
가치가 많이 달라진다라고 저는 생각을
합니다. 오늘 영상은 여기까지
하고요. 여러분들 정말 신축하실
계획이 있다라고 하면은 한번 와서 어
참고해 볼 만한 어 그런 신축
사례니까 뭐 시간 되시면은 여기
학동공은 바로 앞에 있으니까 오셔
가지고 한번 보시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 오늘 영상은 여기까지
하겠습니다. 감사합니다.
[음악]